aussi dans un pee je vous dis j'aime
beaucoup de pays et j'aime les gens en
parlent trop on part gratuitement trop
c'est connu d'ailleurs sepalumic elissa
ok alors on veut toujours sur les
trappes auchan non mais ne pas faire de
drame mais qu'est ce qui veut dire parle
pas assez jeune accusations quoi pour
qu'on en avait parlé dans mon livre de
la pipe du public pour savoir pourquoi
non mais vous me dites c'est à dire pour
le public gbe maintenant sa démission
c'est pas pour vous c'est pas pour moi
non c'est pour les gens qui vous espérez
il régale et garde si le prochain poids
et non mais oui mais des gens des gens
qui me regardent et dirigé par la torah
laissez moi parler parce que moi je suis
là pour parler sinon mes emmerdes
alors vous êtes lacs siphons masturber
vous même